[Music]
in blue man news submitted by pick me a
professional diver is left looking like
a balloon after rising from deep water
too fast
Oh diver died what do you know he looks
like a balloon he looks like a balloon
now I thought that [ __ ] kills you I
thought like it like your box like
bubbles get into your bloodstream and
you [ __ ] die right now oh if you if
you like rise up too fast that's not
this movie where somebody wrote they
went up too fast and they [ __ ] died
mm-hmm and you know movies are all real
what did they explode or something I
think their head exploded or something
yeah like if you want to kill someone
just stablish it and makes him float up
and they died I saw like a movie wants
if it works because I watch this deep
water diver guy like he had to get
hooked to a thing and he had his nose
plug and then he just goes down like
this and it shoots him down but then
like yes go up at a certain speed or
he'll die right yeah and then he's got a
once he gets out of the water like he I
don't know if it's like a certain time
or something he just can't come right
out of the water or else he dies yeah
it's cuz the nitrogen expands like it
creates bubbles in your body
yeah man so if you get out of the water
too much or especially since for this
man his name is Alejandro from Peru he
he usually dives like for his work I
don't even know what I just read such
fear I read it and you guys talk about
helium and balloons and I'm like I don't
know what's going on the second thought
was I should not be here right so
uneducated about what I I know how to
read but what I just read is just
literally words the balloon rising man
dead I don't know even know we're
starting out strong first article
starting
that's the most honest thing I've ever
we all try to pretend that we know what
the [ __ ] were talking about yeah okay so
what's happening here yeah can you read
it no one knows what a conundrum
he is scuba diver and one day he came up
way too fast from being 30 meters
underwater mm-hmm and so when he came up
too fast
there was nitrogen that that formed
giant bubbles in his body oh so this is
what he looks like now dude okay that's
the fastest way to get bod you undo it
looks like there's balloons in his
shoulders this is what immediately do
your [ __ ] job bro it was like a
football player can you just like just
poke with me no this one just deflates
poor guy he lives in pain yeah yes I can
fix it yeah they can't like poke a
needle
they can't deflate him the only way that
he can be cured is by doing is by being
in the this hyperbaric chamber which is
like oxygen therapy it's like oxygen and
a pressurized chamber to be able to
reduce those nitrogen bubbles but this
dude he's I mean he's been going and
he's been able to eliminate 30% of the
bubbles in their society and it sucks
too because they can't surgically remove
him because it's like attached to his
flesh did he did he come up the water
looking like a balloon and float can you
float
that'd be sick if you could like they're
like good body boarder like
you know you don't have to duck type
he'd be the best surfer any spot like
the surfers would be like be scared of
it like all dude you can ride the wave
him I would never be scared to be on a
boat I'm good like so how long has he
been diving cuz he should have known not
to rise up that fast that's like a
rookie mistake that's true I'm not sure
maybe he was like I'm the oxygen and
then some accident happened I had no
idea that happened but you can inflate
like that let's insane well I haven't
even four years ago you still like that
I wonder if it's a good gradual it keeps
getting bigger throughout the day or
like in one just like she almost
exploded that's weird you know what's
weird is like if you look at the picture
his forearm is like normal yeah and then
his bicep and shoulders and his legs are
normal I mean look look at his face man
it says it all I don't even know that
can happen yeah it's crazy cuz like it
actually changed his ethnicity because
he got white yeah he's like Mexican in
the forearms it's hard for me to
comprehend that you can't just poke it
with a hole in it deflates cuz bubbles
deflate and understand I want to
understand the science behind this and
it'll probably be like fighter like MMA
now what happens if you squeezes it hurt
oh yeah it hurts well cuz it hurts them
right the skin is stretching that fast
so he's been living on painkillers for
we all see that yeah
yeah there's gotta be a way to fix that
faster no there's some kind of surgery
right there saying that it would like in
order for him to be normal again
it would require like a hundred sessions
in that chamber yeah he can't get a
hundred sessions in four years oh it's
expensive oh it's a money thing I was
like I think he's he kind of lazy dude
like get in there bro no sir
some organizations should do it for him
just all divers though we should very
strange games that crowd crowd yeah so
please go fund him Alejandro yeah
Martinez he is like the most common name
so if you're watching this please start
a GoFundMe for Alejandro yeah mm-hmm
wonder how much it costs per session so
they were talking about this other
surgery that we're talking about this
other surgery that you possibly get but
it's $100,000 damn what and it's not
guaranteed let's do the hundred sessions
man mm-hmm
I never thought I'd see the day that
there would be a human balloon you can
survive no waste out of movies the guy's
head exploded and this guy lived so my
mind's blown right now so do you think
it's like proportional to like if you
had a choice where would you have like
that blow up your shot that's a good
place just like centaurs don't fit in
just fine I'll be the video everybody uh
prime my calf muscles mm-hmm that's
interesting
opposite of this so I would you don't
say people would look at him be like
dude that [ __ ]
looks like you runs or he's in sure yeah
could you like your calf muscles yeah
you'll never be able to wear tube socks
ever again it's all ankle socks for you
where would you guys let's go around the
table my dick never trying to get laid
again
oh yes that's gonna intimidate the women
because like with your dick and what
inflate long wise what I've been fat
skirt I don't be like this you want
girth yeah you do you know I mean that
help us out definitely be my forearms
cuz like when I'm in flights I get
really sleepy so I can just do this oh
you can't oh you can't you can't [ __ ]
you're not supposed to scuba dive and
fly at the same D know me like what if
it's four years later now can he fought
one I'm guessing since he still has
these nitrogen bubbles it might still be
the same thing I don't know all I know
is I don't need a pillow for the rest of
my life I'll have my neck
looks like a neck brace like so then
it's string and neck toe and it's always
support like this that look like they
had a nickel oh I knew I forgot one
really really it looks like you don't
want to look like that I mean for four I
mean if it has to happen on my one part
of the body I might as well have it here
so then I could use it for something a
little weird bullfrog mmm how about your
earlobe see you know like Buddha oh yeah
and just like any can't like big ass
gauges in them just like stick your hand
back your head so you could just the
front
they won't even trip on you
[Laughter]
Oh big booties need a big booty huh
squad probably but - I mean if I had to
enlarge a part of it yeah but there's a
finish were there there's a finish
somewhere and then I can make a lot of
money off of it like what fetish
websites Oh a fetish I had a moment is
[ __ ] video for the majority of my
life and then I finally saw it
hmm two girls one cup what do you think
is one of the most disgusting I almost
threw up
oh it's not the poo yeah like it popped
up and I just thought come out likes
about the poop the poop just popped out
of the butt oh so uh Vanessa she was
kind of like bluffing cuz she was like
I'm gonna make you watch this cuz I saw
it I was like you're not gonna do it and
she clicked it open and I was like you
can't stop watching it no no I did stop
watching it let's try to come out and it
came out so fast what the [ __ ] yeah and
the music did not make sense to me is it
real did eat it I don't I just watch the
cut I think it's real cool I think they
pumped the butt with chocolate you know
in its word it's a swirl perfect
greenish - hell I'd agree I thought it
was the color of the wall behind you
like it was like antenna like brown
chocolate chips well supposed to be
darker man yeah didn't it like even if
it was cooking here they had to shove it
up her butt first yeah but you said they
injected her but I feel like they did as
possible when the video
I blocked it out I saw it a while ago
see I'm trying to block it out right now
but it's just like they're you know to
me it's just right there in the back of
your mind right here it's [ __ ]
disgusting the same day that I finally
came around to see that video so still
was so curious it was back in like 2010
that same day I ended up seeing this
other video I forgot what they called it
something the games or Olympics or some
[ __ ] where the guys they paint a little
bit something like that where they tie
up their nuts and their dick and watch
this like black and then they top it up
and all like no people do that I don't
know if it was fake or not but I hope
it's fake there's a peanut yourself one
gonna shoved a glass jar up his butt and
it shattered where I was interesting
yeah and there's one here's on that yeah
and there's one guy who tied his dick me
sliced off the tip of it yeah it was
really interesting yeah the one that
really interesting it's not the word to
get off the [ __ ] Internet
um Plexiglas put his balls in it put
another plexi gas glass on top and
screwed it - it was flat what his nuts
yeah yeah oh
Japanese so go back to the pool would
you guys how much would it take not for
you to eat like a good portion of poo is
it real poo a real problem like and I
just had to lick it stops like in a bowl
like swallow again you for $10,000
[Laughter]
thousand a hundred and fifty thousand
just had a hypothetical today but I
started at 20 million you real-time I'll
do it for $250,000 house you were
looking for abortion if it's frozen and
you could put some kind of I'll suck a
dick before I eat some [ __ ] opposed to
eating like a possum popsicle pungent
you say what you wouldn't you wouldn't
okay so what's your number for it think
about that one Oh see how are you this
let's go predict slightly this is really
strange
Jake sucking dude that's that's before
it's a fully erect one and does come
involved no let's say no comes involved
you just got to go at it for a good 30
seconds oh but do I have no eye contact
I could just not just little
I contact more for kisses yeah French
kissing a guy that's it's gonna be very
interesting your compass is sucking dick
over eating a bowl of [ __ ] I can just
smell it real quick I liked how you
looked at us like were the [ __ ] old
guy for like what how many years it's
seven years seven years what would say
that say it again okay so you have to
[ __ ] an old ugly fat man and like pass
them it would be a woman though okay
sorry for 12 years for 12 years 80 83 85
she's gonna live till like 92 at least
four times a week for 20 million when
they die and it's a passionate love - I
[ __ ] you you can't show you'd rather do
that 20 times over then eat [ __ ]
I can't do it yeah I can't know what the
old person can you um like smoke like be
on drugs
that could take your mind you know
you're doing it I said if you smoke like
I don't like some earth like some good
you can be like just looking like no my
stipulation it's it's love you have to
love the ice a yeah because the the
thing is she's nice
well she's very nice to you though she
smells terrible yeah like mothballs just
not a smoke hey it's all about a
personality Gina can you is it do you
have to create you have to cream pie
inside
that's David it's his question do I have
to get cream pie no everybody you get
dust pies I put a token powder in that's
a good scenario I like that what's up
you sexy [ __ ] useless [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you want to follow us you
could check out all our [ __ ] links in
the description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ] other than that videos are up
there
[Music]